[Music]
hey what's up you guys Denny here this
is the daily Denny live and I'm sitting
down with America's Got Talent's latest
champ
mr. Shanley congratulations thank you I
knows only just a couple hours ago yeah
you're the winner me how you feeling
really really happy it kind of feels
like a dream right now
because I'm tired I don't see it's like
you didn't have much time to even has a
sunken at all not really I'm starting to
slowly sink in but it's still kind of
just a crazy moment and I'm still just
so happy I can't stop smiling
you've got to be feeling the love though
I mean the Internet's going mad for you
yeah yeah you know I didn't want to look
at my phone because it was blown up oh
yeah notification is just like squirrels
girl notification I love it you
celebrated last night the way I would
celebrate tell the folks how you did it
yeah well I brought a bunch of the zoo
crew right in my room order in and out
you just have a bunch of in and out and
watched a movie and we just had a lot of
fun that's what you do you got to
celebrate with a double double yeah yeah
I love you you actually chilled with
azúcar oh yeah we've gone to know them
so well ever since even the judge cuts
actually yeah and I've just grown to
love them the Peterson is an amazing guy
and
when I was up on stage with them
actually I was like you know what I've
already done it like no matter what
happens I'm happy because if they win
that would that would mean a lot to me
yeah why I gotta tell you I've been
covering this show for the last couple
years and I think this has been the most
suspenseful yeah results show I mean I
don't know which way was gonna go no
wall see cuz I thought it was gonna go
one way then it completely took a left
turn and that's what that was what was
shocking the other thing is is because
all ten of those acts based on the
performances from the finals I mean it
could have been anybody it'll literally
cuz even when I was down at Yazoo core I
was like I don't know who's gonna win is
so incredible yeah every single artist
was just deserved the top they really do
yeah and I'm honored to be a part of
that group and I gotta tell you were
visibly anxious up there well alright oh
yeah in fact could you see my hand shake
Oh shaking your head was between your
legs I mean for the folks who might have
missed it we're gonna relive it right
now the guys here take a look at the
results show last night
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't write just like wow guys have
you watched that back yet no that's for
side yeah it looks so seem I'm like wow
they did that quickly yeah like how did
they organize that I mean you know we
have quick fingers what's your reaction
watching that that thank you guys like
that that really means so much to me and
like I don't know I couldn't have asked
for anything else better you're truly
shocked weren't you yeah you can tell
yeah I mean I was super stressed I know
and then of course the whole zucrow team
just like leaves you up like that I mean
I can't words can't describe this I love
it I mean what if you can't how would
you sum up this entire experience
because obviously you told me this last
night that you never imagined you would
make it this far because you're a
close-up magician but just card tricks
and yeah and honestly it's unprecedented
that a magician like you has won the
whole thing
but yeah that's right I mean magicians
in general don't really do that well on
America's Got Talent especially when it
comes to the semis and the finals
because it's it's a little bit different
from perhaps learning a song or
something or maybe doing a cover of a
song because you have to actually create
from scratch you know something original
the props the music acting and then the
overall trick itself so it's it is a
little bit trickier but I think the
overall thing I experienced was love
from the whole cast yeah everyone was
just so supportive and everyone wanted
each other do well no one was like
trying to be competitive usually in
competition shows there's always
backstabbing there's always like people
talking behind their backs but in this
case everyone was really really
supportive with each other yeah and we
all respected each other's skills and
talents and I think that is what made it
so special for me did it also make it
harder because you do have those
relationships to see people eliminated
yeah especially last night oh my god
well so you know how I think everyone
was saying how Tyra was taking too long
right announce the names for us and and
I was talking with everyone
we all agreed that she was going too
fast okay because we were like no no no
don't take them away yeah why why are
they why they Oh leaving and
kept leaving boom boom boom and I I was
just freaking out let's enjoy this for a
minute yeah exactly like me and Brian
King Joseph we were just like side-stage
because when we were at the top five
were like I have to say that I felt that
the room changed when Courtney was
eliminated and then when Michael was
eliminated what was your role so so for
me and I think some other people
probably agree with me I thought
Courtney was gonna win yeah just based
on pipe and I guess just talk but all of
a sudden when she didn't make it up five
I was like what mm-hmm that's insane and
then my second pick was actually Michael
Ketterer I thought he was also gonna he
was frontrunner or winner
and then he would got six no fourth
place or is it fifth place yeah fifth
place yeah this place and I was like
what is going on and that just kind of
did it for me because it took like two
left turns
totally and because then you're like I
don't know I honestly don't know woman's
gonna know you're what is going on if
they got eliminated like anyone could
get like you know yeah I mean at what
point cuz you're right Courtney and
Michael in particular were early
favorite so when they were eliminated
I'm curious like at what point did you
realize I might have a shot of winning a
GT I only I only realized that because
Brian King Joseph is incredible Samuel I
find him absolutely hilarious yeah and
zucrow of course they were my favourites
to win I wanted them to win from the
Pyrenees you know why I wanted them to
him because I think what they do is so
unique yeah and especially to America's
Got Talent and so it was anyone's game
it was anyone's game yeah but you won
the game you won the game and I gotta
say there's a lot of congrats coming in
from people who are watching right now
they're really really happy that you won
joanne from facebook says my favorite
congratulations and continued success
edward from facebook says I'm so happy
that shin limb won thank you yeah you
got a lot of fans you know you have a
lot of fans in the fellow judges in fact
I have a little surprise for you I asked
everyone about you and what what it was
about you and your act that kind of like
helped push you cross that finish line
and they had amazing things to say we
actually have that for you right now
take a look
[ __ ] I have to tell you last night was
the best year has been
I mean his performance
it was magical literally [ __ ] like one
and I did say to him yesterday I said
nothing would make me happier than for
you to walk away tomorrow with that
million dollars in here is what are you
happy I'm very happy for him very happy
for him he's amazing you know and you've
worked so hard on his math you know in
order to do all of that you really have
to do hours and hours and hours and
hours to be that quick and that good
what was it about Shin do you think that
just how push him across that finish
line the wow factor and the wow factor
of the last I mean he certainly deserves
to be here and he certainly deserves to
win and in America's Got Talent
nothing is better than seeing a variety
action because we're a variety show but
I think that performance at the final
was far and above anything I've ever
seen to watch a card be held right in
front of you and watch things happen to
it without it going away and being
misdirected it's pretty amazing yeah I
mean they're right though the wow factor
you know and it's kind of a meet and I
have to agree with Howie it's amazing to
see variety act win the show you know
singers tend to do well but like you
brought the house down man like you did
it yeah what's what has it meant to you
to have their support you know there are
people were at the top of their game in
the entertainment industry
it means the world yeah I've seen some
sometimes sometimes they don't like
certain magicians coming into agt
actually I almost didn't do America's
Got Talent
simply because of that I thought maybe
they won't like me with other maybe they
wouldn't like my audition act and I was
very surprised then I keep getting
surprised yeah and I just want to thank
all the judges actually for for helping
me I believe it was because of you guys
that I started to change who I was I
started to improve and become a better
magician you have said that
Simon pushed you you know and yet right
you said that last performance of yours
was because of him right yeah he told me
in the quarterfinals that I needed to in
general I think he was trying to tell me
to get bigger because I was I was doing
too much stuff at the table and it kind
of close and very very intimate but for
Vegas show you do need to show some
variety even if it's just cards
so that really sparked something in my
brain and that's when I said okay I have
to take a risk even though I only had
two weeks cuz because this between
semi-finals my finale it's only one week
difference and so I I really had to kind
of take the risk and just do it you had
to make it bigger and better and
elevated but in a really short yeah
really short so I I don't know how I did
it
actually I really don't you know one
thing that was probably unexpected in
this whole experience was how much uh
Tyra thinks you're sexy I I think she
said it every time even quoting the very
end I believe she said the winner of a
GT is this sexy magician thank you
I gotta I gotta give it to her though
because [ __ ] you had the hair flip going
you know like I thought I was hair goals
but now I'm looking at you like damn I
wish I had that cut oh my gosh is a
crazy man is it part of the act now I
feel like it's like a misdirection move
I do this and then I do something else
I'm down there I'm doing something you
know you can't cut your hair effort now
right I hope I don't lose your magician
it could just appear ah you know there's
a some folks asking what is next
obviously Vegas is coming up right yeah
what's on your trajectory well the Vegas
show with all the other contestant the
top ten I believe and that would be
really fun will be like a family reunion
I think that would be a blast for
everyone to watch but after that I think
I just want to focus on myself if
anything the finale has taught me that I
can grow as a magician I can kind of get
bigger and so I want to focus on that I
want to I want to create a show that's
special and yeah Vegas worthy yes yes
Lady gaga run for our money in Vegas huh
I mean also then your personal life too
you have a fiance right you're engaged
so we be working on the wedding you guys
play yeah I think she's kind of figuring
on that crazy on my end but yeah
sometime next year
you guys okay so you're are you gonna
enjoy the engagement for a little bit
longer yeah yeah yeah
try to have the wedding in Hawaii okay
do you want me asking how did you
propose did the ring just appear out of
the cards well yeah well it wasn't
hearts I actually did a trick when I
proposed to her it's it was actually on
stage while she was performing and I
kind of appeared so so she was actually
performing for a different magician it
wasn't me
Oh and I was I was in a different
theater but we were in the same hotel
yeah and so she was doing her normal
routine and then me and the magician
like quietly switched without her
knowing and then all of a sudden she
sees me on stage she's like what is that
like what are you doing
and in her routine she's an ice princess
who receives a light from the magician
okay so instead of the light I made the
light turn into a ring good that's
really really good oh how romantic
okay well she's got a good one America's
got a good one last question is Emily
from Facebook she wants to know will you
go on an international tour you want
travel the world with your eyes of
course you think I think internationally
would be great because I perform
silently I love that what do you want to
tell your fans the ones that voted you
and got you to exactly where you are
right now thank you so much to every
single one of you who voted for me like
I really really appreciate it I I wasn't
expecting it at all to win or to even
get this far so thank you for believing
in me and thank you for giving me the
confidence to to keep going so I love
you guys yeah that's amazing Shannon
well congratulations dude you deserve it
I cannot wait to see you in Vegas
seriously I know you got a busy day
ahead someone let you guys go oh thank
you guys for tuning in optimal we back
with another daily Denny but we have
covered a GT all season long so head
over to ET online.com for all those
goodies including my interview with shin
and his fiance that's on our website as
well are you guys have a good day
[Music]
you
[Music]